jack lang dans le vaucluse avait joint
la romaine en particulier on a mis en
cause des délivrances de permis de
construire dans des zones dangereuses
vous même vous êtes maire d'une grande
ville de blois à votre avis je dirais
d'une ville d'ailleurs dont une partie
peut être éventuellement inondées par
les crues de la loire
absolument alors donc vous êtes donc il
ya des hauts il ya des zones non
constructibles et en tant que mère je
veille avec soin à éviter toute
construction sur ces zones dangereuses
mais vous pensez que les règlements sont
assez restrictif et suffisamment
contraignant la matière de l'allemagne
ce qui allait les permis qui sont
délivrés un peu n'importe comment
il faut pas mettre en cause à la légère
telle ou telle autorité
j'imagine que le maire de vaison la
romaine gère de son mieux c'est cette
commune
seulement il n'est pas fou qu avec la
décentralisation qui a été une bonne
chose peut-être n'at-on pas pris garde à
mettre en vigueur à ce nombre de
précautions qui assurerait de façon plus
rigoureuse encore le respect à la fois
de la sécurité et de l'esthétique et je
pense que le moment venu il faudra
peut-être réviser un certain nombre de
réglementations
alors il ya une autre question qui se
pose c'est qu'à visons la romaine
apparemment il n'ya que le pont romain
qui a tenu le coup alors n'est ce pas
pour vous ministre de la culture un
thème de réflexion quant à la qualité
des architectures modernes aussi
expliqué que ce pont précisément non
seulement a tenu le coup par la qualité
de sa construction mais aussi par son
emplacement
mais ce n'est pas faux parfois il
faudrait méditer les leçons des anciens
leur mode de construction
le choix des sites le choix de
l'urbanisme et l'architecturé
contemporaine a aussi ses belles
réalisations qui sont plus solide qu'on
le pense jack lang écouter cet après
midi dans les arènes d'orange la soprano
barbara hendricks a chanté au profit de
toutes les victimes de ces orages
meurtrier
politique 50000 grands électeurs
essentiellement des élus locaux ont
renouvelé aujourd'hui un tiers du sénat
une élection qui débouchera vendredi
prochain sur un changement à la
présidence puisque alain poher ne se
représente pas alors nous avons en
direct à l'intérêt ce qui se trouve au
sénat alain tavares at on déjà des
résultats précis et d'écouté on a une
grande partie des résultats il n'y avait
plus de 100 sénateurs à renouveler je ne
vais pas les citer tous sachez
simplement que on se posait la question
de savoir s'il y aurait des conséquences
du référendum sur cette élection la
réponse est non il ya eu le référendum
d'à côté aujourd'hui on est revenu à des
problèmes de politique intérieure pur
j'avais presque dire à des clivages
surtout deux parties très nette
donc les grands électeurs car il s'agit
d'eux qu'ils ont des îles et sénateurs
aujourd'hui on choisit j'allais presque
dire presque comme par le passé le seul
gagnant de la journée
c'est le groupe socialiste du sénat qui
dispose ce soir de cinq élus de plus
mais cela ne change en rien la majorité
qui reste fortement ancré à droite rpr
udf à tous les trois du df et udc donc
rejoigne une des deux tiers de cette
majorité c'est à dire donc il n'y a pas
de problème est que le futur président
dont vous avez parlé sera
obligatoirement un homme de droit dont
parmi les hommes forts et les images
fortes que l'on verra les nouveaux
hommes du sénat aujourd'hui la pierre
mauroy
au ps l'ancien premier ministre qui a
été élu et aussi deux membres du
gouvernement michel charasse dans le puy
de dôme et jean marie rausch en moselle
michel charasse a réussi à tenir tête au
député maire de chamalières claude wolff
qui était envoyé par valéry giscard
d'estaing lequel brigue peut-être un
nouveau mandat de député au mois de mars
prochain
et puis plus compliqué l'élection de
jean marie roche un homme d'ouverture
entre guillemets jean marie rausch
acquis certainement la droite a renvoyé
entre guillemets l'ascenseur car il
avait laissé son siège de président de
conseil régional dans des conditions
particulièrement délicates vos souvenirs
ya quelques mois au profit de gérard
longuet parti républicain un autre
perdant c'est une figure du ces
centristes paul alduy
le maire de perpignan alors voilà ce que
l'on peut dire ce soir maintenant
évidemment voyez quel beaucoup de monde
est la question que l'on se pose c'est
qui sera le futur président du sénat
alors il y a deux hypothèses soit le
groupe udf c'est à dire républicains et
indépendants et centristes se mettent
d'accord pour trouver un seul candidat
ça paraît impossible parce que ça s'est
jamais produit auquel cas le rpr les
préfère messi
décès les centristes et les républiques
indépendantes présentent des candidats
on part de rené monory chez les
centristes on parle monsieur larcher
chez les républicains indépendants et
surtout de pierre christian taittinger
et bien charles pasqua qui est au rpr et
qui pourrait dire j'y vais à ce moment
là se présenterait également ça va être
absolument difficile tant les ascquois
qui dit ceci fernand charles pas ceux
qui menacent commeinhes qui menace parce
qu'il craint que le groupe socialiste et
certains élus centristes fasse bloc pour
désigner un candidat et charles charles
pasqua annoncé qu'il se fâcherait pour
les législatives c'était le cas merci
fernand vous retrouve en compagnie de
gilles leclair vers 22h45 dans soir 3
pour une édition spéciale en direct du
sénat chaque langue
certains voient dans le sénat une
institution un petit peu décevante
est ce votre cas je n'ai pas une une
institution d'une d'une grande modernité
et avec la chambre des pairs de la
grande bretagne 7 qui n'a semblé qui
représente une mineure à l'époque et
puis disons cette son mode de
composition fait que le sénat pour
l'éternité tout au tout au moins tout le
temps que le sénat continuera à exister
sera toujours une assemblée
conservatrice puisque encore une fois il
n'y a aucune chance en raison de la sous
représentation des communes urbaines
dans le choix des délégués qui élit les
sénateurs
jamais on peut le dire le sénat ne sera
composée d'une majorité progressiste une
étrangeté de la constitution française
l'opposition continue à durcir le ton
vis-à-vis du chef de l'état jeudi
dernier jacques chirac avait estimé
qu'en cas de victoire de l'opposition
aux prochaines législatives
françois mitterrand devrait en tirer les
conséquences et partir aujourd'hui
françois bayrou le secrétaire général de
l'udf a déclaré que le chef de l'état ne
devrait même pas attendre cette échéance
à la place de monsieur mitterrand voyant
le désaveu mais je crois avoir dit ça à
peu près dans les mêmes termes il ya un
an
voyant le désaveu au calme à majorité va
être exposé je considérerai que ce
désaveu frappe non seulement les
exécutants mais l'inspirateur et
l'inspirateur et à l'elysée et il me
semble qu'il serait normal et légitime
mais c'est une position de laquelle pour
ma part je n'ai jamais bougé vous le
savez il serait normal il serait
légitime il serait souhaitable que le
président de la république en tire lait
conséquence est ce qu'il peut en
devancer les conséquences je ne sais pas
c'est à lui de le dire que vous êtes un
intime du président de la république
première question comment va-t-il je
crois qu'il se porte bien et qu'il est
en convalescence et vous le savez c'est
un homme qui a en lui une grande force
et une grande énergie et c'est une
bataille qu'il gagnera contre contre la
maladie alors on l'a entendu certains
leaders de l'opposition demandent son
départ pensez-vous d'abord que c'est une
idée qui l'a effleuré après le oui au
référendum
je ne pense pas je pense que comme il
l'avait expliqué il s'agissait d'une
élection touchant à l'avenir de l'europe
n'avait pas de rapports avec des
préoccupations de politique intérieure
il avait clairement dissocié le vote des
français en faveur du traité et les
échéances de politique intérieure alors
mettons-nous justement dans l'hypothèse
d'une nouvelle cohabitation je deviens
l'hypothèse d'une nouvelle copie
cohabitation que pensez vous de la
déclaration de jacques chirac qui estime
que le président devrait partir
franchement je suis choqué par ces
attaques constantes permanente contre la
fonction et la personne du chef de
l'état il n'est pas convenable il n'est
pas normal on parle beaucoup de dignité
à propos de cette question il n'est pas
normal n'est pas convenable qu'en
permanence des hommes d'état puisse
ainsi mettre en cause la constitution le
mandat du président de la république est
d'une durée de sept ans je crois que le
devoir premier d'un homme d'état et de
respecter les institutions de respecter
aussi je dirais la personne du chef de
l'état l'offre en france le débat est
libre et ouvert et je sais que je ne se
prive pas de multiplier les polémiques
mais en même temps je trouve qu'il ya
certaines limites à ne pas dépasser
j'ajoute que si ces attaques contre le
chef de l'état et contre la constitution
elle-même se perpétuer on l'aurait
offrir en présence est étrangement dans
un grand pays civilisé comme la france
d'une sorte de prononce
lamento institutionnels par conséquent
une élection législative vaudrait
élection présidentielle n'a pas de sens
je crois que en tant que juriste que je
suis il faut respecter les échéances et
les actions d'autant plus d'autant plus
que rien n'est écrit à l'avancé
rappelez vous voici quelques mois
élections en grande bretagne tout le
monde prédisait la victoire des
travaillistes
ce sont les conservateurs qui ont gagné
croyez-moi marche prochain n'est pas
joué il aura beaucoup d'eau qui coulera
sous les ponts et je ne parierai pas sur
la victoire de ceux qui aujourd'hui
parlent haut et fort contre la majorité
actuelle en roumanie 16 millions
d'électeurs étaient appelés aux urnes
aujourd'hui pour élire leurs députés et
le président de la république qui en ce
qui concerne le président cela devrait
se jouer au second tour entre le chef de
l'état actuel l'yonne iliescu et le
candidat de l'opposition centriste emil
constantinescu reportage à la campagne
dans un milieux conservateurs
pascal verre d'eau et philippe dix jours
de fête dans la campagne roumaine sur la
route de pau festi ce matin à 20 km de
bucarest la mariée respirait le bonheur
avant de voter ares traditionnels auprès
du puits
le jeune couple béni les badauds et les
amis asperges la terre pour la rendre
fertile carmen la paysanne soutient le
président il est ce coup car on le voit
à la télé une telle rigueur oui je pense
qu'il est intelligent intelligent quoi
un peu plus loin les observateurs
étrangers observe un scrutin sans
passion et irrégularités l'opposition
est représentée dans chaque bureau de
vote
en appliquant sa tête tous constaté que
la loi est parfaitement respecté qui lie
à une arène progrès par rapport à moi de
mai 90 bureaux de vote 62 les
grands-mères hésite
est ce en raison du nombre de parties
plus de 80 ni lire ni écrire ça fait
rien mettons douala 30 décembre l'un des
villages rasés sous ceausescu on vote
avec discipline mais sans consigne
particulière fouad officier le capitaine
lui a choisi le candidat d'extrême
droite est candidat idéal pour l'armée
s'était dit moi en tant que citoyens
roumains
je crois que nous narre le patriote
finalement l'enjeu de cette élection
c'est tout simplement de rattraper
d'histoire dans tous les pays de l'est
les dirigeants néo communistes ont été
balayées alors les lecteurs roumain
dira-t-il au président idée ce coup nous
ne voulons plus de disciples de
gorbatchev
réponse dans quelques jours formule 1 et
de 9 pour nigel mansell qui a remporté
cet après midi le grand prix du portugal
le champion du monde de volant de sa
williams renault a franchi le premier la
ligne d'arrivée devant l'autrichien
berker sur mclaren honda et son
coéquipier ayrton senna
une course qui a été marquée par un
spectaculaire accident
riccardo patrese qui a accroché au
moment où vers guerre a brusquement
freiné pour rentrer aux stands la
williams-renault de l'italien est
heureusement retombée sur ses roues mais
vraiment frôlé la catastrophe un grand
prix qui a été marquée aussi par
l'annoncé de l'arrivée d'alain prost
chez williams renault la saison
prochaine didier chaumont qui pourrait
bien provoquer un tel attroupement à
l'entrée du motorhome de chez williams
one knows c'est un approche en personne
qui a tenu à confirmer son arrivée la
saison prochaine dans l'écurie franco
britannique faisant taire du même coup
un bon nombre de rumeurs le concernant
seule certitude pour l'instant le triple
champion du monde français fera ses
premiers tours de roues dans le baquet
de la williams-renault mardi prochain
sur le circuit d'estoril
alain prost visiblement soulagé et
heureux de retrouver dix ans après en
formule 1 elle fait renault l'objectif
d'alain poste maintenant est simple
transformer en succès son association
avec william soient nos avec un
quatrième titre mondial mais avec quels
partenaires le mystère reste entier
tous les scénarios ont été envisagés le
nom de son compagnon de route le plus
souvent retenue par les spécialistes le
britannique martin brundle de chez
benetton ford brundle 6e actuellement au
classement du championnat du monde
viendrait épauler alain prost dans la
course au titre
décision avant la fin de la semaine
prochaine enfin le moteur renault fait
l'objet de toutes les convoitises
il pourrait bien quitter ligier pour
rejoindre mclaren pendant 48 heures dix
mille bâtiments généralement réservé à
d'heureux privilégiés ont ouvert leurs
portes au public depuis 1984 c'était la
première fois que la journée du
patrimoine duré deux jours et ça n'a pas
été de trop pour satisfaire les milliers
de visiteurs jacques garnier
quant à les voir de préférence la ferme
et des plaines on se trouve sur la
commune
l'an dernier ce fut un franc succès
cette année c'est paraît-il un crayon
les français sont fiers de leur
patrimoine
tout ce qui touche au passé ou à la
richesse de leur pays ne les laisse
indifférent ils ont été près de 8
millions au cours de ces dernières 48
heures à découvrir au revoir des
milliers de monuments témoins de leur
histoire la neuvième édition de cette
manifestation coïncidait avec la
célébration du bicentenaire de la
république
pas étonnant que l'assemblée nationale
ait fait battre bien des coeurs
républicain le 55 faubourg saint-honoré
demeure du chef de l'état n'a jamais vu
autant de curieux pacifique et
respectueux leur seule arme aujourd'hui
était la patience ces rendez vous avec
l'histoire ont une qualité essentielle
celle de montrer que la france est un
pays riche
tous ces biens exposés sont autres
propriétés et nous avons raison d'en
être fier
si au cours de l'histoire les français
aient été consultés par voie de
référendum afin de se prononcer pour la
sauvegarde éternelle de leur chair
patrimoine pas de doute possible cela se
solderait cette fois ci par un véritable
oui des clans vous êtes un ministre de
la culture heureux ce soir ça a bien
marché
un mot quand même l'autre oui est aussi
un véritable oui oui à l'europe
mais c'est vrai que ce soir des
monuments historiques ont été
plébiscités comment vivez vous cet
engouement des français
d'année en année je crois que
l'information l'effort des pouvoirs
publics des propriétaires privés des
collectivités locales et puis ce goût
retrouvé de l'histoire et de la mémoire
et le goût des belles choses tout
simplement il n'y a pas un endroit dans
notre beau pays qui aujourd'hui ne soit
jalousement préservé conserver entretenu
et je m'en réjouis beaucoup
naturellement les tailles à sa part et
d'année en année nous avons réussi grâce
au soutien du président de la république
à augmenter les efforts budgétaires pour
les monuments historiques et l'année
prochaine dans une situation financière
qui réclame de la rigueur nous pourrons
à nouveau augmenter le poids de 7 % les
crédits de restauration des monuments
historiques lors cette année le
commentateur l'évoqué très justement
c'est le bicentenaire la république
et rappelons-nous que
avec la révolution des biens qu'ils
aient des propriétés privées de
monarchie ou de l'église où
l'aristocrate sont devenus des biens de
la collectivité
je suis très heureux que en ces journées
où nous célébrons la proclamation de la
république 6 millions de visiteurs et
découvert leurs monuments parce que ces
monuments sont la propriété des français